It's been some time since He-Man ruled the world,
but the once-mighty TV and toy phenomenon is
finally ready for a reboot. Whether you're a
longtime fan or a newcomer, here are all the
reasons why Netflix's Masters of the Universe
will blow your mind from here to Eternia.
It took what felt like forever, but
we now have a definitive answer:
"Masters of the Universe: Revelation" will
debut on Netflix on Friday, July 23, 2021.
When filmmaker Kevin Smith, the geek icon
producer of the "Revelation" miniseries,
first announced the show at
Anaheim's Power-Con 2019,
it was difficult to tell just how far along
the series was in the production pipeline.
But the team behind the show obviously
went right to work if they managed to
wrap up production in the year and half since
then while in the midst of a global pandemic.
We should note that July 23 is
only the first part of the season,
with five episodes going up for streaming on
that date. Hopefully, we'll get some indication
about the second batch of "Revelation"
episodes soon after the initial premiere.
Smith took to Twitter in November 2019
to share that the voice cast was about to
begin recording their parts, so that means
the second half shouldn't be too far away.
If this is the case, Netflix will need
to figure out where it can fit the second
half of "Revelation" into its release
schedule; of course, we'll be keeping
an eye out for an official announcement, which
we expect to arrive sooner rather than later.
Netflix doesn't shy away from positive PR when
they know viewers are flocking to a new show, as
shown when "Bridgerton" obliterated all previous
records for viewership on the streaming service.
If "Masters of the Universe: Revelation" turns
out to be the hit that Netflix hopes it will be,
they won't waste any time moving up the release
of the remaining episodes for the series.
"Masters of the Universe: Revelation" is
already proving to be far glitzier than
the '80s series we all know and love with
its illustrious cast of triple-A talent.
He-Man will have his shouts and war cries
powered by Chris Wood of "Supergirl"
and "The Vampire Diaries" fame. The
biggest get of this series, however,
is without a doubt Mark Hamill; in
a truly inspired casting choice,
he will be lending his incredible voice
talents to iconic villain Skeletor.
Hamill may still be most well known for playing
Luke Skywalker in the "Star Wars" franchise,
but he's almost as famous for his stellar body of
voice acting work — he has consistently performed
an animated version of the Joker since the '90s.
More recently, he has been putting his evil shriek
to work as SkekTek the Scientist in the other
big '80s nostalgia revival series on Netflix,
"The Dark Crystal: Age of Resistance,"
so becoming Skeletor is a perfect fit for
his style. What can we say? He's very
good at those unhinged evil cackles.
"Here is the answer we seek.... Life everlasting!"
The celebrity train doesn't stop there, as we
continue down the long list of Eternia's friends
and enemies. The cast includes Sarah Michelle
Gellar as Teela; Liam Cunningham as Man-At-Arms;
Lena Headey as Evil-Lyn; Diedrich
Bader as King Randor & Trap Jaw;
Alicia Silverstone as Queen Marlena, and many
more. There's even a role for Kevin Conroy,
the Batman to Hamill's Joker in "Batman:
The Animated Series," as Mer-Man.
"Hello? Hello operator? I believe
my party's been disconnected."
Netflix's sparse webpage for the
upcoming "Masters of the Universe:
Revelation" series has a brief one-sentence
blurb as a summary of the show. That reads:
"After a calamitous battle fractures
Eternia, Teela and an unlikely alliance
must prevent the end of the Universe
in this sequel to the '80s classic."
Exciting, eh? Netflix's teaser doesn't
provide much more context than that,
but by the power of Grayskull, it does feel
like a direct continuation of the 80s series,
complete with 95 seconds of action set to
Bonnie Tyler's "Holding Out for a Hero."
"At the beginning of our first episode,
it plays for the first ten minutes
like a slightly, or way-better
animated version of the old show."
There is an interesting nugget
buried in the producing credits:
the VP of Mattel TV, Rob David. At first blush,
that's no big deal, because it's very common for
executives of intellectual properties
to receive executive producing credit.
The twist here is that Rob David also came up
with the story for a 15-issue "He-Man" comic
series titled "The Eternity War" that
was published by DC from 2014 to 2016.
The comics' story isn't centered
only on Skeletor and He-Man. Instead,
it's about a no-holds-barred war for the soul
of Eternia, with big battles, noble sacrifices,
and bloody carnage. While this new Netflix
miniseries is likely not a direct adaptation,
elements from the comics could be incorporated.
What the plot of "Revelation" will probably
not include, considering their absence
from the cast list, is He-Man's sister
She-Ra and her many ancillary characters.
Netflix's "She-Ra and the Princesses of
Power" animated series has no announced
connection to Revelation, and the two
shows likely won't connect at all,
because "She-Ra" has been running just
fine on its own steam for four seasons.
It appears that we'll just have to wait to see
exactly what kind of story Smith and company
are cooking up for us. Fortunately, the wait is
nearly over, and with all of the love that Smith,
David, and the rest of the crew are pouring into
this adaptation, we're not worried in the least.
If you had any worries about the professional
credentials of the crew behind the scenes,
the composer for "Masters of the Universe:
Revelation" should ease your fears.
The animated Netflix show's composer is none
other than the award-winning Bear McCreary.
Longtime fans of "The Walking Dead" were
introduced to his music from the first moment
of the opening credits, and he remains one of the
longest-tenured people attached to the AMC show.
His career has spanned multiple genres
and mediums. McCreary got his start in
television on the 2004 version of "Battlestar
Galactica," where he scored almost all of the
76 episodes of the sci-fi hit that
spawned a new generation of fans.
From there, he continued his
work on television by composing
music for several seasons of "Eureka" and
"Terminator: The Sarah Connor Chronicles."
McCreary's film work is rooted in
horror, where he created the music
for films like "Rest Stop" and "Wrong
Turn 2: Dead End." As his star rose,
he scored bigger and more widely known movies,
including "10 Cloverfield Lane," "Godzilla:
King of the Monsters," and the
2019 reboot of "Child's Play."
One of his biggest professional
accomplishments in recent years,
however, has come in the form
of video games: specifically,
2018's "God of War." The PlayStation
4 exclusive was a mega hit for Sony,
selling more than 10 million copies in a little
over a year after its release. For his work on the
Norse mythology-inspired action epic, McCreary won
a BAFTA and four Game Audio Network Guild awards.
Kevin Smith revealed McCreary as
the composer in February 2021,
and the @NetflixGeeked Twitter account posted a
video of Smith's reaction to hearing the "metal
maestro's" work for the first time. Smith is
left visibly teary-eyed by the end of the clip,
which should tell fans of "Revelation" that
the music is in the most capable of hands.
For those of you who just can't wait until
July 23, Dark Horse Comics is getting a
top-tier team of writers and artists to hold
you over before "Masters of the Universe:
Revelation" premieres. Four issues of a prequel
comic, also titled "Masters of the Universe:
Revelation," are scheduled for release, with
#1 now available for pre-order everywhere
comics are sold. Kevin Smith and Rob David,
two of the names behind the Netflix show,
are also in charge of writing the comic
series, along with Tim Sheridan, known for
his work on the "Superman: Man of Tomorrow"
and "Reign of the Supermen" animated movies.
The comic has some heavyweights in the visual
department, as well, with drawings by Mindy Lee,
known for the comics "Bounty" and "Crimson Lotus",
color from Rico Renzi, who you may know from the
comics "Spider-Gwen" and "Sundowners", and letters
by Deron Bennett, known for his work on "Batgirl."
Stjepan Sejic, a veteran of "He-Man: The
Eternity War," drew the cover of the first issue,
and Dave Wilkins will provide covers
for the remaining three issues.
Each issue will have at least one variant
cover, drawn by many other talented artists.
The release of a comic book
for "Masters of the Universe:
Revelation" is a nice callback to the original
'80s cartoon, which also contained comic books
that were included with the release of each new
action figure. This prequel is said to explore
the aftermath of an attack on King Randor,
He-Man's father. The creature sent in the
attack is somehow linked to He-Man's sword,
and he sets off after Skeletor and Evil-Lyn.
"Masters of the Universe: Revelation" #1 will hit
comic shelves and digital storefronts on July 7,
2021. The other three issues will release on
August 11, September 8, and October 13, which
should help hold us over until the second half
of the "Revelation" series premieres on Netflix.
As we mentioned earlier, "Masters of the
Universe: Revelation" isn't the only revival
of this series in the works for Netflix. Mattel
and Netflix are also collaborating on a totally
separate production, simply titled "He-Man
and the Masters of the Universe." Unlike
the anime-inspired "Revelation," this show
will reportedly be a more traditional take
on the "Masters of the Universe" mythos, with the
target audience reportedly skewing much younger.
At the moment, details on this
new "He-Man" show are very scarce.
We know that the storylines will be new, and
that Skeletor is the center of the conflict.
The onslaught of "He-Man" lore hasn't stopped
there. An additional "He-Man and the Masters
of the Universe" animated film is also in
the works, as well as a live-action movie.
No matter what, it'll probably be better
than the last time they tried that.
"I'll be back!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.